[Musique]
pour faire une pâte à crêpes je mets une
libre de farine une demi livre de sucre
2 cuillerées d'huile 4 cuillerées de
sucre vanillé une pincée de gros sel je
mélange la farine tout l'ensemble
et j'ajoute un verre d'eau le j'ai mis
six heures pour la quantité de farine de
sucre alors voulait travailler pour être
très fort pour obtenir une pâte bien
qu'on creuse et l'amérique quand même à
la main plus possible ensuite georges
dinel vous la laissez reposer
oui six heures
elsa ya le temps de lever comme on dit
fin le 22 qui fait le vin c'est le gros
sel c'est la crêpe dentelle que ça
s'appelle sur la crêpe dentelle à la
main et vous lui faisiez vous les faites
toujours au feu de bois ou c'est dans
l'ancien temps qu'on le fait c'est dans
l'enceinte en moi j'ai appris à faire
les crêpes j'avais 11 ans et je les
faisais au feu de bois et ensuite mon
dieu le progrès est l'unique chose qui
n'est pas désagréable pour nous parce
que on peut tout de même être moins de
chaleur dans dans cette cuisson en
chimie ou ce bois c'est très chaud et
très dur à endurer
c'est un meilleur taux mal ça
certainement xi madame parce que ça
donne un autre goût ses meilleurs coups
gas la cuisson est plus régulière
également mais on ne peut plus le faire
on tournait plus maintenant de
crespières qu'il est prêt au feu de bois
c'est ça s'est terminé ça
[Musique]